is just too big of a personality I think
he's a cabinet secretary because cabinet
secretary your name will be constantly
in the news you can go on TV all the
time you can create policy you could you
could be a you know be ready prepared
for
2028 VP I think he needs someone like
Trump needs someone like a Tim Scott a
more cmer Carson par Carson Tim Scott
just sorry keep the alpha that Trump is
and I feel like Vivic is an alpha but
more refined like you said would just be
too much together it's just you can't
put two electric like Outlets you can't
put two positives together would just
spark too much right you can't do that
yeah Secretary of State what do you
think Secretary of Energy Secretary of
Commerce maybe Chief maybe uh you know
Chief of Staff but person might be too
big for Chief of Staff just he needs a
front- facing position because he's so
good on camera he's really Charming he
can really communicate a message think
about him on TV every week Meet the
Press or you know National talking about
Economic Policy you run circles around
these people